We mentioned a few paid options and
finished up the paid marketing portion
of the lesson with some of the basics of
paid social media marketing channels.
However, social media is integrated so
well into our lives
that there are many ways to leverage
social media for your business for free.
The idea is use social
platforms to encourage people
to spread the word about your
app within their circles.
The first step in doing this is
to engage the community online
using social platforms.
This is where we are going to start
talking about free marketing methods for
your business.
After we talk about the free social
communities to help with customer
acquisition, we're going to
look into inbound marketing.